Dean McCaw has felt liberating coming
out felt liberating and it is scary and
I believe that if I lived the way like
being queer that I was going to be evil
so I worked really hard to be
to be anything but that they got to a
point where I thought maybe it's better
if I'm not here David Archuleta gets
emotional during his Mass singer reveal
and brings panelists Ken Jiang to tears
I can either confirm nor deny that but
yes it happened during the season
show which saw the top two performers
Medusa and the Macaw battle it out one
last time
[Music]
the golden mask trophy ultimately goes
to Medusa later revealed to be British
singer Bishop Briggs
foreign
but before she was unmasked David aka
the Macaw had to take it off
recording artist David Archuleta
and that's when things got emotional
with Ken explaining the Deep connection
the singer has to his family involving
David's time on American Idol 2007
American Idol was my favorite season of
all time I still remember David
archuleta's first performance he sang
such a stirring rendition of Imagine
[Music]
[Laughter]
when my wife was on bed rest in the
hospital not knowing whether our kids
would live or die we would watch Idol
every week and you were like a ray of
light
for my family oh and it's an honor to
see you in this capacity thank God for
you and I love you there's this lovely
Again part of the part of the beauty of
the show is just when it's at its best
it is just it's everything it's laughter
it's music it's emotion it's connection
and I think that honestly keeps me
coming back to the massinger season
after season is the connection and as
David shares how his decision to come
out publicly changed his life he
couldn't hold back his tears I believe
that if I lived the way like being queer
that I was going to be evil I realized
I'm I can't change this so if anyone
else has grew up you know feeling like
they were bad just because of who
they're attracted to and who they loved
I want you to know that it is worth
taking the courage to show your true
colors it's scary
but you're you're worth you're worth it
despite David being runner-up once again
on a singing competition show he still
won the hearts of the mass singer judges
[Music]